[Musik]
jetzt hoffen die kicker und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ja dich
auch natürlich euch jedes gut heute
haben wir mal wieder was ziemlich
interessantes vor
es gibt schon zwei paar ski auf jeden
fall ab falls sie noch nicht gesehen
habt wir machen heute den dritten part
von echteste tip top live acts also
funktionieren die wirklich oder weniger
fällt weil das ist gerade irgendwie so
ein trend auf techno gibt es ganz viele
live hacks und echt verrückte sachen
manchmal weiß man nicht okay ist dass
marc lieb ist das zauberei oder klappt
das wirklich physikalisch chemisch
biologisch englisch ich warte auf jeden
fall einkauft und habt ihr im versand
gekauft die wir heute brauchen heute bin
ich gut vorbereitet
juli hat schon gefragt weil sie den
letzten platz musste er einmal helfen
und aus seinem zimmer irgendwelche
sachen rauskramen die ich nicht mehr
hier hatte ich hoffe natürlich dass alle
fünf live funktionieren
wir fangen wir an mit dem ersten der ist
wirklich krass irgendwie hat er keinen
ton dabei
[Musik]
das war's auch schon manches klappt ich
bin gespannt warte das einzige was wir
brauchen ist ich habe diese stifte
gebraucht ich weiß nicht weil permanent
machen wir keinen sinn aber war dass
normales wasser oder irgendeine lösung
das ist ja ein amerikanisches video
diesen stift in die hacken ich weiß
nicht ich kann nicht sagen was es für
eine war
ich halte es für am wahrscheinlichsten
das ist ein ganz normaler pool schiff
war wie diese hier sonst was ja auch
noch irgendwie andere stellen und hier
wurde erst wirklich einfach ein
strichmännchen gemalt was sich dann
praktisch abgelöst hat wir schauen wir
ob es klappt ich fange einfach mal an
ich denke schon dass das möglich ist
ich weiß nicht vielleicht ist der
stiftung bis hin zu weg 1 ich glaube
nicht dass es mit den stiften gehabt war
nicht der kamera direkt auf das
menschliche
er sollte ich doch auch nein nein das
musste ja wegziehen irgendwie werden wir
auf das männchen gift klar ich mache das
jetzt einmal an verschiedenen schriften
gegen einer geht schon dabei sein
probier mal was da passiert wasser keine
vernünftigen stift oder com probieren
ich habe keine vernünftigen wir fangen
wir von hier oben an ja ich gebe jetzt
hier was da drauf
ganz langsam
es kann sein dass zusammenschlägt ich
will jetzt hier nämlich gar nicht sagen
das ist das ist absolut fähig ist und
nicht funktionieren kann deswegen sage
ich mal
ich weiß es nicht weil ich habe echt
viele videos gesehen wo es geklappt hat
bei mir hat es jetzt leider nicht
funktioniert
ja aber jetzt ist hier dieses der
abonnent männchen auf dem teller und wir
haben eine man wird sich wieder auf
reden leute wenn ihr in den stift kennt
bei dem das funktioniert schreibt gerne
in die kommentare oder wenn wir da
irgendwas falsch gemacht haben
aber so richtig geklappt hat es leider
nicht leute jetzt wahrscheinlich freuen
sich jetzt alle warum hast du im
wohnzimmer klopapier es für meine kaffee
ecke jetzt kommen wir zum nächsten der
wirt krasse ohne schweiß da freue ich
mich drauf ich denke der wird klappen
weil es meiner meinung nach auf jeden
fall wirklich ist aber ich würde es mir
erst mal sehen ich habe ihn gerade hier
seine box gekauft extra die halt auch
nicht zu hoch ist
glas brauchen wir noch und ich muss
wasser rein wir machen wir mal kurz ein
gefäß wechselt dass wir uns irgendwie zu
klein moment wenn dann richtig
ich kann das ja gar nicht mehr
von h
verbrennung liege also welches sich zu
verbrennen
ja natürlich das ist wie bei so einer
taucher blase weißt du so müsste das
funktionieren nur die kerze brauchen
natürlich weiterhin sauerstoff ich mache
jetzt einfach geil alter und jetzt
stellt sich natürlich die frage also
irgendwann ist der sauerstoff hautnah
aufgebraucht nicht gleich jetzt deswegen
mache ich es mal eben hoch als sie es
schon aus um das war's ich wollte ja
auch noch nach oben bringen wieder das
muss ja auch gehen oder jeweils ich dann
glaube ich das ding nicht erfüllt ich
sage das geht was auf so und jetzt noch
mal ganz vorsichtig erst das teelicht
ins wasser das wäre doch gelacht wenn
wir das nicht hinkriegen und runter bis
unten hierzu laden es langsam wieder
hoch aber ich glaube es ist möglich ist
ja auch egal
wir haben auf jeden fall bewiesen dass
israel kein fake let's go zur nächsten
sache sowie was auch das nächste bringt
einen gegenstand zum fliegen was meinst
du welcher gegenstand wird sein
von allen sachen die auch unterstehen
der t das könnte sein
vielleicht auch nicht ich zeig dir erst
mal hast du schon mal im fliegenden
täter gesehen automatisch naja man aber
wir sind ja auch hier um dinge zu ändern
sagt riegler war es intel vor allem
wichtiges projekt ist erfolgt
aber ob das klappt
[Applaus]
keine ahnung
ich glaube die ganze zeit nur noch
gebeutelt gehen ja nicht zu hause
nachmachen
das kann sonst brennt nach eure wohnung
oder haus machen wir gemacht man dass
man jetzt am besten auf sagt wir machen
es jetzt genau wie im video
jetzt haben wir den teebeutel ich stelle
jetzt mal hierhin sich nicht bewegen und
ich war eigentlich keine unterlage weil
das hebt ja im besten fall forderte
sprint und haben wir ja genug wasser
[Musik]
es ist hochwertiger 94 x 5 auf einmal
machen könnte einmal ich das nicht
vielleicht bis hin zu gefährlich wir
machen 5 auf einmal okay leute werden
uns jetzt erstmal auf drei geeinigt
metzger schon live kann man ist sich
einer nach dem anderen
hui und ab geht's da kommt wieder das
erträgt und die verbrechen hat auch alle
genau passend also ist nicht gefährlich
oder so konnte ein familiärer
vorschlagen oder das zeigen ohne scheiß
hätten wir so was damals im
chemieunterricht gemacht oder
physikunterricht wie auch immer wer
schon geil gewesen
ich hatte die ganze zeit mit teebeuteln
kommen wir zum nächsten tag auch
interessant ich sage aber im vorhinein
also den finde ich aber sehr kritisch
ich weiß nicht der hat das hier mit dem
iphone nix gemacht kommen
nicht geschafft also jetzt gesehen der
macht erst oben das aus dann zieht das
runter dann machte den rechner an und
dann kann das hochziehen und ist drin
und er hat einfach nix ganz gerne bei
meinem versuchen das fake zu 100 prozent
aber es hat über eine million weit so
also es gibt eine million menschen dass
dieses ding gelaufen würden zeigen dass
genau wie er es gemacht hat
rallye barbaren barbaren waren barbara
barbara und dann kann man es eigentlich
jetzt hier entsperren von iphone ist
aber es funktioniert wird keinem iphone
hat schon früher damit angefangen weißt
du was ich glaube der hat halt einfach
phaser dich an dann geht es ja auch ist
ja klar oder
weil er ohne eigentlich geschnitten oder
irgendwie fällt weil das funktioniert
einfach nicht oder kein gericht ist und
was für eine sicherheitslücke wäre das
denn für apple bitte also das
funktioniert nicht
leute das würde ich auch sagen also bei
mir das nicht funktioniert haben 20 beim
iphone nicht getestet aber ich sage
einfach machen aber ich mir ziemlich
sicher dass es fähig ist man muss ja
auch sagen so generell der ganzen heck
videos war so da gibt es eine menge von
ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass fast
also das nahezu keins davon funktioniert
einfach weil ihr müsst euch vorstellen
dass es so ein großes unternehmen die
haben wir extra leute die genau diese
sicherheitslücken täglich ausbessern und
das ist ja wirklich eine sehr leichte
sicherheitslücke dann die könnte man ja
innerhalb von von von einem update fixen
deswegen garantiert verein habe ich noch
hier geht es jetzt um so polaroid bilder
weist die werden praktisch ja also du
hast so tolle bilder von diesen kameras
in sex oder so heiß und das bild hast du
dann schön und gut aber du hast es ja
nicht digital und in diesem hack wird
jetzt gezeigt wie man das ganz einfach
in richtig guter qualität aufs handy
bekommt ob das funktioniert schauen wir
jetzt mal an
[Musik]
wir probieren das jetzt natürlich mal an
sich hat das überhaupt gar nichts mit
einem polaroid bild zu tun weil du
kannst jedes dokument scannen ich will
jetzt einfach mal ein polaroid bild ich
hab' ich habe dort kein voller reuth
bild aber ich habe jetzt einfach mal
hier dieses biltgen und auch sehr
schlechte qualität von mir und meiner
freundin jetzt models und so
oder seid ihr euch noch gut da wurde
auch ein bisschen wie so ein pony mit
meinem haben na ja aber was ich sagen
muss ich wusste gar nicht dass wenn man
jetzt hier auf notizen geht hat ein
neues dokument erstellt und dann hier
auf die kamera drücken kann um dann
dokumente zu scannen wusstest du dass du
es wackeln kannst wie wackeln geben
notizen fehler gemacht hast oder
ausgelöscht hast kannst du das handy
einfach war mit zwei kammern eingabe
widerrufen dann kannst du alles löschen
oder dann geht's halt zurück zum letzten
step sowieso ich schreibe mir übels
lange notizen und dann musst du einfach
so machen die krasses muss ich auch
meine texte hochladen und als live act
verkaufen leute folgten auf tik tok alex
laufs alex heftigster und länger ich
habe 200.000 dollar was wollt ihr
eigentlich alle einig dann würde ich
sagen wir versuchen das jetzt mag dieses
wunderschöne bild einzuscannen dokumente
scannen und ach so komme jetzt kannst du
das hier noch so ein bisschen anpassen
sowie uns gern behalten
wow
das bild glänzt haben guck mal wie es
bei mir geworden ist haltern krass gut
also jetzt auf jeden fall gut geklappt
da es ist anscheinend möglich ich muss
nur sagen an sich ist das für mich kein
live das kenne ich schon längst also ich
hab einen scanner alb und wenn ich
irgendwas einst gern möchte dann kann
ich das natürlich so machen die qualität
von den dingen wird aber nicht wieder so
gut als hätte man das selber irgendwann
mal mit dem iphone geschossen das hätte
ich jetzt gemacht bei diesem effekt
deswegen würde ich mal sagen ist zwar
kein fake aber ob man das jetzt wirklich
so braucht keine funktion bei notizen
einfach kurz einzuscannen klar
also geben wir jemanden daumen nach oben
kein fake ich weiß ja nicht unbedingt ob
es fotos gedacht ist wahrscheinlich auch
er seine dokumente generell trotzdem
hoffe ich dass wieder leicht gefallen
aber nicht den kanal
wir sind eine millionen weiß gerade gar
nicht genau doch schon videos fall
kompliziert instagram alex w wir sind
uns morgen 19 uhr wieder gibt es neues
video